hey everybody i'd like to welcome
the filmmakers of boys state um
jesse moss and amanda mcbain and i'd
also like to welcome stephen garza who
is the subject
the memorable subject of this movie
hello stephen how are you
hiya nice to meet you and i see you
excellent
so we're talking we're here to talk
about a specific scene
from this remarkable movie which of
course
is set in texas and um maybe you could
fill me in
on uh one thing before we start
how did you guys pick stephen how did he
become part of this movie he's he's in
this scene and i want to know
where you found him and why he's so
important to this film
well i i think he he kind of picked
himself um
he's such a singular young man that it
was hard not to notice him even though
he wasn't the loudest voice in the room
and
so many boys in this particular room
where we met him were
just sort of um they were loud and and
sort of i think trying to cast
themselves in this film
and stephen he has a kind of old soul
quality and i noticed him out of the
corner of my eye
i think he just captured our imagination
we didn't think he had a chance
snowball's chance in hell of doing well
at boys state but we just loved him and
we loved how serious he took politics
and
his background so he was kind of our
underdog
i am third oldest i'm the first one to
get past freshman year of high school
i'm on the course to be the first one to
graduate from high school
[Music]
so it's almost like uh i have to succeed
you know a parent telling you that
they're proud of you is one of the most
amazing things you could ever hear
in your entire life so talk about the
scene where we're about to
to go through and and also in
a way that'll give you an opportunity to
be more specific about
what those cameras had to actually
accomplish
the scene that we selected to talk about
is really um
as his campaign is building and stephen
has become it's a little bit of a
spoiler but he's become
the candidate for governor for his party
the nationalist party
and there are two parties of boys state
federalists and nationalists and stephen
this unlikely underdog
is been selected by his party to be
their candidate's voice in the storm
[Music]
stephen
and he's about it's we're entering the
kind of climactic
final vote to see if he'll be elected
governor and this scene is
really a chance to for steven to talk
about his politics his campaign
how he's chosen to conduct himself at
boys state which is very different than
some of the other boys we meet
in the film and um he takes us down to
the texas state capitol which is an
extraordinary building and he
he takes us through the legislative
chamber where you see all the boys have
taken over passing bills first about
banning prius drivers and sort of jokey
things but then actually now they're
debating really serious stuff
like uh passing uh background check
bills and
things that really matter in people's
lives so it's a chance for us to follow
stephen into this space
but i've had to listen to people who
have said things that i vehemently
opposed and disagreed with
we agree that we do need to work to
identify illegal immigrants
for their own safety it's not just for
the safety of the nation but i listen
with an open mind
so i propose a law to where law
enforcement can still use drones out of
their line of sight
there are a lot of people that i've met
that have different lives than i have
their upbringing what issues affect them
next thing we know
there were gunshots and everything it
happened in the art hallway
so can feel carry i feel is here to stay
because
in my hometown rolling oak small was
shot up but
someone with a concealed carry license
was able to fight back people don't like
the word compromise
but there's so many things that we've
been able to come together
background checks this is nonpartisan we
are simply making sure
that guns do not fall into the hands of
those who will use them to harm other
people
so um you used that moment uh
uh to to create this great uh shot
uh tell us you know what inspired you
guys
uh to to film it the way that you did
the main event was um was make or break
right if we did not capture something in
that moment the lightning in the bottle
if it did not exist we would not have a
film and i think that kind of pressure
um was was new to us but also kind of
wonderful i mean it was a new challenge
and we really had to hold on tight and
it was very risky i think that what
is so powerful to me is sort of
stephen's initial um idea there
in the campaign is what he used
throughout that entire week
um which couldn't have been easy right
stephen i mean you definitely had to
listen to a lot of
politics you don't agree with yeah it
was um
thinking about it right now that i i
follow a lot of conservative media not
because i agree with it but because it
challenges me to see why is it that why
do you believe
what you believe the way i wanted to run
my campaign
was very different from most i wanted to
know what was on your minds and ask you
what issues matter to you
i didn't want to run a campaign i did
not want to run a campaign
to represent y'all if i didn't know who
was going to represent i didn't know
y'all want y'all to sign
a bad check with my petition so i'm
really proud of the 30 signatures
that i got admittedly it is not easy it
is very difficult to kind of bite your
tongue and
you know uh sometimes it gets the better
of me where it's just like you're
absolutely 100
wrong um you know but you just kind of
step back and realize that
a message of unity won an election
flip georgia got 80 million votes and
it's kind of getting to know
what issues are affecting you that maybe
we're ignoring or that we're not
thinking about the right way or that
brief
you know haven't addressed properly to
make you vote in the way that you did
as a person who's you know part of a
partisan political party
[Music]
well stephen um i am putting my faith in
you
to figure this all out and amanda and
jesse thank you for making this movie
very provocative i hope everyone sees it
and uh
we're gonna wrap this up thank you all
thanks ann
thank you anne
[Music]
you